como é se o de sabão em pó menino
correndo com a blusa branca na lama e a
mãe sorrindo Olha que coisa linda Ah meu
filho correndo na lama essa blusa tão
Branca tinha vários preto e azul lá
dentro mas ele quis correr com a Branca
vou deixar a minha mãe não deixa não
porque ainda perto não existe lama eu
não saio da casa Eu não chego a sair da
casa Eu não chego a sair do quarto Eu
não chego a sair do banheiro botou a
blusa branca ela manda eu tirar que ela
sabe que a vai acontecer a qualquer
momento a do comercial não ela F ai
coisa joga joga joga lama meu filho vai
da de motocross ô coisa linda meu filho
com essa blusa tão Branca ô coisa linda
Aí ela bota sabão em pó depois passa
fica ó Aquela animaçãozinha a sujeira
Vai Saindo Vai vai ver minha mãe cada
Gotinha de lama é um xingamento aqui ó
ela ela lavando aqui essa desgraça Só
serve para sujar vocês estão precisando
tem ter empregado Ó o tamanho olha ó o
tamanho da Mancha eu vem cá